i'm curious because this is a little bit
of gossip
you're rumored to be on the short list
to direct uh
superman tiffany that is news to me
you you have you have broke the news to
me
the news break live on msnbc
yeah no i have not heard that just
now news to us as well but something we
love to hear
following reports that warner brothers
plans to develop the first black
superman film
speculation has begun about who the
studio might tap to direct
and regina king was surprised to hear
she's on the list
you and barry jenkins both your names
have been thrown out there
anything you want to tell us is there
any news you can break this morning
about those conversations
speaking with msnbc's tiffany king over
the weekend regina king seemed genuinely
surprised she was being considered
and although she wasn't able to speak to
the rumors king did tease her newest
project
bitterroot i think there are people who
want to see us particularly as you're
directing bitter root i have to tell you
my friend and colleague dr jason johnson
is a huge fan he's so excited
he said please ask her about bitter root
so really quickly we're out of time but
can you just tell us really quickly
uh what we can expect from you in
bitterroot
well i am so excited as well um i
i'm i'm partnered with a wonderful team
in in ryan coogler's proximity and and
legendary so we are developing
uh this uh story right now we are
in the process of writing the first
draft and
um i i don't think i can say anymore
but i am excited about what's going on
and the entry point that we've decided
to um
enter the story i'm really excited about
that
and for those who don't know this isn't
regina's first step into a comic
universe
king also starred in the popular series
watchmen which earned her the emmy last
year for outstanding actress in a
limited series or movie
now back in february warner brothers
announced that celebrated author
ta-nehisi coates
would be pending the screenplay for
their black superman feature with jj
abrams producing
and according to the hollywood reporter
warner and dc are looking to black
directors to ensure the project has
perspective and depth
floating other notable talent like black
panther director ryan coogler
creed 2 director stephen cable jr and
judas and the black messiah director
shaka king
and of course when it comes to who might
star as the man of steel
well back in april michael b jordan
spoke out about the rumors he was on the
shortlist to be cast
telling the hollywood reporter quote
it's definitely a compliment
but i'm just watching this one so who do
you want to see attached to the project
are you excited that dc and warner are
expanding their cinematic multiverse
let's talk about it in the comments
below and make sure you check back in
with us on june 9
for the premiere of loki see you then
you